now to a situation most parents will
recognize you've recorded the cutest
video ever of your kid your hearts
bursting with pride and you want to
share it widely so you posted on YouTube
but after you hear this you may want to
think twice about doing that our YouTube
editor till baller is here to explain
why till what's the issue here so as you
may know kids videos are insanely
popular on YouTube and this is what I
mean a single video can get hundreds of
millions of views like this one for
instance has close to 220 million views
and we're not talking about high quality
video production this is just a simple
homemade video no fancy editing no
effects so the problem now is of course
you don't know who's watching
unfortunately videos like this attract
pedophiles and this has always been the
case but with YouTube there's a whole
new dimension of problems added to it so
for once there's the YouTube
recommendation algorithm so let's say
your pedophile and looking for a video
of a girl in the bikini you only need to
find one video like this and then the
recommendation system keeps feeding you
more and more and more of the same
videos and one of those videos might be
a video of your child and then secondly
there's the comment section which
enables users to put like innocent
videos in a sexualized context and also
to interact which is which each other
and to to build like a community okay
well even mention algorithms as being
one one part of the problem algorithms
are programmed by people right what is
YouTube doing about this yes in fact
YouTube just announced that they are
taking actions so for once they are not
allowing minors to livestream anymore
unless they are accompanied by an adult
but this
raises lots of questions so this will
also be controlled by an artificial
intelligence but how will it a I tell
the difference between a 17 year old
miner and an 18 year old young adult and
what does it mean to be a company Disney
adult always have to be in front of the
camera so I'm very skeptical about this
because AI has shown time after time
that it's not true reliable then
secondly YouTube says it's disabling
comments on videos featuring miners and
we took a look but then what we saw was
that there are lots of problematic
videos featuring miners with the comment
section still open so YouTube's AI does
not seem smart enough to correctly
identify all the videos that would
require protection just we only have a
little time left what's the solution
that how do we deal with it yeah
ultimately this is a move in the right
direction
but unless the platform would completely
block videos featuring miners this won't
go away so ultimately it will be the
adults and the teenagers who have to
decide do I want my video online and
available for the whole world to see
which just may include child abusers
till thank you very much a very
difficult problem and an important
problem needs to be tackled there till
bowler our YouTube editor here at DW